Discoverers have changed our planet.
Its inventors have made you the man you are.
They have imagined, found, and demonstrated everything.
The moon that gravitates and the apple that falls in dismay.
They sought to measure time that tells the hour.
They wanted to offer us all the guarantees of happiness.
An exemplary light that illuminates, that prospers, and opens the way to human dreams.
They found levers to lift the world, and thanks to them, the earth wanted to play in circles,
Turn, turn all the wheels of locomotion and of the automobiles that follow one another.
Thread wires, then quickly cover them.
Horses are ready with other chimeras so that the discoverers progress in the wisdom of our old earth.
Discovering them.
No, but I wasn't asleep.
No, I was thinking.
Today's news.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, of course.
To think that I almost forgot.
Oh no, but I didn't know that.
But where is it?
Well there you go.
That's new.
And still this stupid violence.
Oh, what a world.
Ah, the results of the football match.
Well done, worms, tomorrow it's going to rain.
Oh, did.
You do that on purpose, stepping on my feet?
Yeah, because you nudge me in the neck.
And all you do is talk nonsense.
And all you do is annoy me.
Oh, well, that doesn't change anything, you too.
Oh, well, you're there, didn't you hear?
I was reading.
Writing is really extraordinary, isn't it?
Printing.
Oh, what an invention.
Yes, but who invented it?
We don't know exactly, but we think the first ones were the ah.
Well, it's up to you to guess.
Okay.
The teachers, I'm sure.
The Greeks, it must be the Greeks.
It was Gutenberg, of course.
No, the Chinese, it was the Chinese, I bet.
Ah, lost.
It was long before.
These are the Sumerians in the Middle East, three or four thousand years before our era.
They exchanged five sacks of wheat for the key and the key.
Oh, the invention of writing is no small feat.
Around the same time, the Egyptians invented hieroglyphics, a sacred script, and almost
at the same time, the Chinese.
The Chinese, again, the Chinese.
Always the Chinese.
Yes, the Chinese invented a lot of things.
By the way, see for yourself.
For over 2,000 years, people wrote like this on strips of bamboo that they rolled up to
make books.
It was by combing.
For example, look at the library that a scholar had to take with him.
I'm going on a very long journey.
I'll also bring back my treatise on populations, not forgetting the one on astronomy.
Let's see, let's see, we mustn't forget the books of poetry, I'll need them.
Oh, and also the writings of the sage Confucius.
Oh yes, the mathematics treatise and the geometry treatise.
I think I have everything.
Yes yes yes, we can go.
I forgot.
No no, that'll do, that'll do.
But whoa, my medical texts.
I can't leave without my medical texts.
And also, that's it.
Master, we can leave now.
Yes, yes, I think so.
Are you sure, master?
We're not forgetting anything.
No, no.
So let's go.
Come on, honey.
Hooray.
My advisors, your majesty has summoned us.
Yes, Nightbot and you, my invaluable advisors, I really need your advice.
Take a look.
These bamboo books are too heavy and too cumbersome.
On the one hand, they tire me out and on top of that, I break my nails.
What I want is for you to find me something else.
You can write on silk, your majesty, it's light.
But too expensive, you want to ruin me.
I think I have an idea, your majesty, but give me a few days.
Good, whoever finds the solution will be richly rewarded.
Let's follow him, let's follow him.
If he has an idea, we'll find out very quickly.
Trust me, most honorable taigyu.
And we're going to steal his idea, isn't that so esteemed nightbot?
Yes, and collect the reward.
That's what I was looking for.
A very nice wasp's nest.
Oh, and an empty one at that.
let's see if the wasps can do that i could do it too look at night pot he's taken a wasp's nest
that's strange but maybe that's his idea we'll see no it's messy it's a pain oh look over here
what a piff what a piff when i think we could have stayed at home peacefully with a nice cup
of tea yes and look i just invented paper quickly ink yes wait i'll be there for a moment and yes
the chinese again they invented paper but they're going to keep their secret it will take the
europeans over 1000 years to learn how to make this paper and for printing it will be exactly
the same still the chinese what are you doing bitch are you wasting time again no i'm actually
trying to save some you see look instead of cutting out each page of text all at once that
will only be used for that page we can prepare the letters in advance and assemble them page by page
it's messy it won't do anything listen i'm paying you to help me engrave pages not to tinker or have
fun what are you making now huh what is this thing let me explain seven euros has characters
arranged upside down look all you have to do is press a piece of clay onto the character to get
the right side up impression then you assemble the desired letters it's too complicated your
invention doesn't look like anything else that's the whole problem with inventions it never looks
like anything else. And yes, Bang was right. It would take another 1,000 years for printing to
develop in Europe. Oh, 1,000 years, that's a long time. And who's the inventory then? Oh, it's not
easy to answer. There were so many people that we don't really know. However, history has retained
one name. It's Gutenberg, of course. I think it's time we went back. Yes, let's go. Antoine,
there's something I'd like to see before it's too late. Okay, I can see. And how much are you
selling your poor man's bible for? Half a florin. Well, I'm telling you, that's expensive for a poor
man. Ah, well, that's a lot of work, huh? But once in a lifetime, everyone can buy their own bible.
So you learn. Oh no, you know, I don't have enough money yet. You see, Anton's system isn't
practical at all, and the book isn't very pretty. All the letters are different. It's messy. In my
opinion, we can do better. Yes, I can see. Quite a bit. No, no, it's bad. It takes too long to make.
We need to find something other than wood. You'll find out. Come on. We need to get to work now.
You're clumsy. You don't miss a thing. It's not my fault. It sticks. Look. Oh. Eh. What are you
doing? Look. Not what. It's the imprint of my foot. Well, that gives me an idea. Listen,
you tell them in the workshop that I'm sick. But. Hey. Well, I'll have to find something other than
clay. Plan. It melts easily. I'll try. Oh. That's better. It doesn't hold. It gets damaged
by grass. Ah, we have to find something else. So, does it work? Alas, no, lead gets damaged over time.
We'll have to find something else. Can you lend me some money? I need a furnace. A furnace? To melt?
Other metals? Try other mixtures. Do you really think this will lead to anything? Maybe, we'll have
to see. Look at this. It cost me half a florin. That's a lot of money and for poor quality. If I
succeed, we'll make a fortune. Thanks, friend. So this time, I think it's done. Dot. Oh, yes.
I added antimony and I'm also trying with a little sulfur. With sulfur? Are you sure?
It should be good. Well, I have another idea. Hey, could you lend me another florin? Huh?
I've already lent you five, Hans. That's all my savings. I've got nothing left. But this time,
I'm getting there. Do you really think so? I'm certain of it. Come back next week,
I'll prove it to you. Hem. You see? Well, with this punch, I'm going to imprint a letter in the clay
and do it several times. All the impressions are the same. Perfect. I'm pouring my secret alloy.
What do you mean, secret, but not for you. There's lead, slate gold, antimony, and copper. Look,
that's the work. Well, say that. Now you're going to see the result. It's beautiful. We can do better
because, you see, I'm hitting it with the mallet. It makes the board vibrate, and so the impression
isn't the most perfect. But I'll think about it. Hey, could you lend me some florins, please?
But H, I've already lent you some. Let's see. 7, 9, and 11. Okay, that's fine. It doesn't matter.
Here, come on. Let's get to work or we'll get fired. Taste my Alsace wine. Fragrant like a
bouquet of violets. Golden like angel hair. But what's wrong with you, H? It's not right.
I saw an absolutely extraordinary idea at the inn. Come and see. Tell me. Innkeeper.
Can I see your wine press at 20?
The Aria Boutique is off limits to customers, but if you take a shopping cart, it can be arranged.
And how much is it? Let's say a Maravice.
I don't have any change. Do you want it, Antoine? Well, let's.
See. So can I see it now?
Can you see it?
Yes. I said you could see it.
To touch it, you'd have to take another pint. You can touch it.
But to be able to operate the mechanism, you'd have to.
Well, you see. You see what I mean.
Okay, okay, okay, but you'll have another small pint.
I understand.
It's, it's, it's very clever.
The pee-pee.
Yes, yes, the pee-pee at 20.
Come on, let's go.
Yes.
And wait, have another small pint.
Come on, I'll give you that one.
You give me now, let's see.
3 and 6 p.m. at V10.
It's an investment for research and development.
Yes, development.
Yes.
Come in.
Oh, but now, Antoine, you'll see.
What's this? Are you going to make wine now? No, my friend, I'm going to make books, lots of books,
beautiful printed books that will sell like hotcakes with this kind of wine press.
Look closely, Anton. Hold this for a moment. Wait, you'll do that later. Look, you see,
I place a sheet of paper on the form and I tighten it. There you go. The ink soaks in
without tearing the paper. You have to wait a little, but not too long, otherwise the ink
might smear. I unscrew it. Look at that. Wow. That's extraordinary. It's even better than
feminine. You're reversing it. You did it. Oh. Oh my god. I've ruined it. It's just a sheet of paper
on Tony. We're going to print some more and we'll get rich. But there's a little problem.
Ah. And yes. I need a thousand florins. Oh. One thousand florins. That's a fortune. And if I
understand correctly, you don't have them? No, you borrowed 15 florins from me. My savings of 10
years. Hello, I'm at Hanspurs. Yes. I have a proposition for you. Come in. My name is Peter
Schoffer. I am from Mayo's. I have come to see you on behalf of Johan Fust. He is my father-in-law.
It so happens that he has heard about your work and would like to help you. But this is interesting.
Very interesting. Well, Mr. Burt, I think you will be happy to return to Malenz, your hometown.
to discuss it. I have enough money to buy you a good horse. We can leave tomorrow. So,
I would like my friend Anton to come with us. He is going to take care of my finances.
You think this is very useful, huh? I agree if you insist.
Good. Ah, dear Mr. Gutber, what a pleasure to see you here with your friend of course,
but sit down, gentlemen, books are selling rather well. The people are learning to read
and the scholars are furnishing their libraries. Now, they say that you have perfected an excellent
printing technique. What a marvel. The letters are neat, well drawn, and similar to each other.
I am ready to finance your printing business. We will be partners. How much do you need? Well,
I would need 8,000 florins. 8,000? H, that is a very large sum. Enough to buy a castle and a few
farms, but I agree. Hell, here's the form that contains the characters. It is perfect. Are you
on loan, Mr. G? Not quite. I want to print 200 Bibles on parchment and paper. For the parchment,
we need the skins of at least 8,000 calves. We will buy the paper in England and we will need
three more presses. And all this will cost another 8,000 florins. 8,000? Another 8,000 florins. Okay,
I will let you go ahead. Here, Mr. Gutenberg, please sign here. But it says that I must pay
you 6% interest. Oh, just a formality. Let's not forget that we are partners. It's for a small
interest in making false profits that can be considerable. Don't worry, we'll sign.
No. You can now order the parchment and paper. What a marvel of a finish. Exceptional quality,
a fortune. Well done, sir, for playing us fart. Finished. One more page. Page 302. Finished.
Mr. Fust paid 16,000 florins.
The Bibles are worth the same, but then you'll still have the printing press.
You're finally going to become rich, H.
What I want is for everyone to have a book.
You'll see, Antoine, the simplest of peasants, will have his own Bible.
We are looking for a certain H. Duber, a citizen of the town of Malins.
That's him.
H. Duber.
Yes, as you wish.
There you go.
And so, as a result, the court of justice sentences you to the confiscation of all your
property. For what reason? You borrowed 16,000 florins from Mr. Fust, on which you were to pay
an annual interest of 6%. You did not repay it. The seizure was therefore ordered. But we are
partners. The Bibles are almost finished. Their stomachs will repay the debt. I am only carrying
out orders. You are being expelled, Mr. Gutenberg. These men want to take over our printing press.
This one came to us for forgiveness. E. Hans, Hans, wait for me. I am coming. Listen,
Hans, none of this is important. Believe me. We will start all over again. You will see.
Trust me. Look, all is not lost. I still have money. I have three husbands left. That is not
fair. Justice, you know, is not always very fair. It is not a sad story. Gutenberg wanted everyone
to have books. And well, I think he succeeded. By the end of the century, 10 million books had
been printed. Today, 10 billion are printed a year. Yes, more than there are human beings in
the world, and that's not counting magazines and newspapers, discoverers shape better worlds
for us, their thoughts wander, their eyes turn to the sky, stars, planets, comets, now
man is discovering, he is about to leave the earth, my words are that he is taking flight,
tomorrow, they will lead us to other firmaments, because for man, his novel is only beginning,
discoverers, discoverers, discoverers,